so let's start with when should you
build a growth team what do you think I
think you know most companies think
about building a growth team when they
have strong retention that's you know we
touched upon this in the last office
hours as well but when exactly is that
right you know for many companies it's
roughly when you have maybe 15 to 20
people in your team at least two product
managers and if you have figured out
that you have strong product market fit
with retention then the third PM that
you bring on the team might actually be
a growth PM and so that may be the time
when you start investing in a growth
team but you know it's never too late to
invest in a growth team but too often
the mistake I've seen most companies in
Silicon Valley do is they actually wait
too long but it's not you know it's not
like it's not like the consequences are
the negative as long as you realize that
the team is actually helping and you
have formed the team many of you know
put them in place in the right direction
the companies that I've actually done
this early have benefited a lot from it
since slack to give you an example was
actually one of the very few companies
that hired a growth PM 14 months after
launch and I think it was roughly 1
million DEA use so fairly early in its
evolution but it really helped you know
having a growth team in place helped
accelerate the entire company towards
scaling it from like 1 million to 5
million views in less than two years
which is no easy feat so the sooner you
invest the more benefits you get but the
most important thing is you should know
when you're ready and for that you need
to look at retention mmm ok which a
great thing yeah I agree I think the
biggest mistakes people make is that
they don't look at retention and they
don't really know when they have product
market fit and they fundamentally
haven't built something that people keep
using on own again and that's not the
right time to build a growth team you
still have to figure out why is the
product not good enough WAIS retention
solo why is it decline to CRO
effectively once you figure that out the
growth team can help you with many
things but there are many specific
funnels the drives towards your product
value that you can
and oh I mean I've seen pretty much
every single step you can make massive
increase increase on if you just have
this laser focus that a growth team can
have okay and do you have benchmark
retention numbers that you advise people
to like look for at the yeah yeah I mean
I think that's another mistake companies
do which is they don't really benchmark
retention to the peers in their space
more vertical and it's extremely
important to do that so to give you some
examples you know for example you know
even if you if you look if you are
building a social network right you
should have long term retention of 50
percent or more because if you're
building a messenger someone should be
checking in daily if you're something
like a Facebook people still 50 percent
of them still log in daily but if you
have if you're building a social app
that less has less than 20 percent
retention in month six or month twelve
like that's worrisome right so you
should really pay attention to what your
sort of space or vertical ascent now if
you are an on-demand delivery company
yeah the median retention you know long
term is usually twenty or thirty percent
so they don't have to have fifty or
sixty percent but for them twenty to
thirty percent means it's probably good
retention the general rule of thumb we
often tell companies is if you have
anything less than twenty percent like
you've got a start paying attention you
know no matter what space you're in so
there you have some sort of a benchmark
depending on wherever you are you can
sort of pay attention to like is this
really week retention or not but beyond
that you have to start paying attention
to what space you're in and sometimes
the periods also differ so for on-demand
delivery companies we actually look at
it depending on food or ride-sharing
versus grocery you can actually do it
weekly versus monthly you eat food
weekly you tend to order weekly
ride-sharing you take trips two or three
times a week so weekly makes more sense
something like travel like Airbnb it's
more yearly you don't travel every month
right so defining the period and then
benchmarking what your long-term
retention is was as your peers become
extremely important so that's tricky so
say your Airbnb and you're only a year
old do you what are you looking for and
retention if it is actually an annual
well that's a classical problem when you
companies go and raise money so my
retention curves or my retention data
set it's too small that's why when you
start a company you should start
tracking those key metrics that mattered
for your business if it's bookings if
it's deliveries if it's orders or
whatever it might be just make sure
you're tracking from day one because
they will matter and someone's going to
want to look at them when you're raising
money if you let's say I've been at it
for a year or like like like say
everybody's first year and there's if
you look at the potential cycle is
yearly well there's a lot of predictions
probably will predict like the next
booking and you can start looking at
them at some point you're going to be
like yeah there seems to be a strong
enough prediction let's say coming back
and searching with dates that's a strong
enough prediction that I probably will
book if I find something that's good
okay cool and on that point I would add
like return visitors is a way to sort of
engage that was this booking one of the
things you still have to keep in mind
you know and I was there even in the
early days of every event everything
most investors could not comprehend that
because they didn't know is this really
sticky or not one of the reasons why I
took you know Airbnb maybe harder in the
earlier years to race was exactly that
because it was travel velocity fuses
really low and you know there was not
enough predictability on retention so
it's a great case study for our founders
out there if you're wondering you know
should I keep at it or not find other
ways to measure customer engagement and
you can teach the investors on what
those metrics should be and how you are
building confidence that the retention
will look good so I also want to clarify
that the term retention might to some
people sound like oh this is just the
growth teams kind of like their own
metric that we don't have I don't care
about growth and to worry about
retention well think about it what is
for attention it's like a representation
of the value that someone gets out of a
product and no matter if you care about
the word retention or not you care about
growth theme you want to build a product
that people get a lot of value from and
it turns out their retention is just
like a really really good way to measure
the value you get out of that product so
it actually applies to everybody no
matter if you believe in what growth
teams does if you believe in the term
retention it just applies to everyone is
just not a choice really just making a
better product
yeah and so at the point that you know
you know you've decided that you're
gonna build out a growth team what does
that first hire look like what do you
look for in that person so I well
there's there's one thing there's the
personality of a person you want to hire
and then there's the discipline that are
old you're looking for okay
generally for personality I look for
people that are curious so a good
example of this is like what's the first
website you look at when you come in the
morning well if that's the dashboard
that's the experimental analysis you're
a curious person you're curious to see
what the results of the thing you
shipped yesterday is or or what the
metrics are doing or try to kind of tie
in the numbers with the thing that
you're building so that curiosity is
super super critical the second thing is
just someone who has a low ego like
you're going to have to throw you away a
lot of code you're going to see a lot of
results that basically might be
contradictory to what you believe and
you just have to like deal with it
because like you don't naturally know
you don't actually know what's going to
work and you have to like be fine with
we're trying a lot of things whether
that's an engineer with a designer
wouldn't work manager you just have to
try a lot it links and then someone
who's who can quickly can't get to the
point of like what's an MVP or what I'm
trying to build what is the smallest
possible test I can run to test this
hypothesis that I have and it usually
doesn't mean you have to spend a month
building something it usually is a lot
less now in terms of the disciplines the
most important person is an engineer so
if you're just a product manager or just
design you can't really do anything for
just engineering often kinship something
so usually starts with the engineering
the critical role south of that is is
someone who's whose data savvy doesn't
have to be the product manager you can
start with the engineer itself start
with it with an analyst or data
scientists or a product manager and then
you want basically you basically want
these things to come enhance the sort of
an engineer get someone in understand
some data then maybe add a designer than
another engineer eventually a product
manager kind of come that comes that way
but but very often product managers
plays this early role of leading this
team which is typically why product
managers are often in the very very
first incarnation of these proteins
yeah and that's something we heard when
we were talking to a lot of the growth
teams as well
one additional new ones which Gustav
but I'll mention it is Gustav himself as
a former founder and we actually saw
that you know at least 40% of the growth
genes that were led in Silicon Valley
were former founders so we asked some of
the CEOs why that was the case and it
goes to the point that Gustav mentioned
earlier which is you have to be self
initiated and so comfortable with
throwing away a lot of code because a
lot of it is experimentation so you need
someone with a lot of grit who can
withstand a lot of failure and would
still keep pushing to figure out the one
third of those experiments that's gonna
make a meaningful difference and where
do you find that characteristic usually
in founders it takes a long time to
persevere so I think it's no coincidence
that you see that it's not a must have
you've seen growth teams that have been
very successful without founders - but
it is an interesting observation that
you know a good chunk of the drug teams
are actually led by Pharma founders and
we've also heard that from CEOs saying
they explicitly try to hire a former
founder in that growth PM role if they
can because they are looking for that
experimentation mindset and the reason I
got into growth in the very early days
was that I was building a product that
wasn't growing problem and let's say
you've worked in a very big company that
never had a problem growth you just free
you just always have growth well then
you're not gonna you're not gonna start
thinking about what matters to growth
you're not gonna look at these Forum
forums you're not gonna look at this
specific funnel and try to care about
what matters because growth is always
there but for a founder everything
matters like literally every single step
matters when you're starting from
scratch so I think that's probably the
reason why this works really well if
four four five people who found a backer
and how do you found these people I mean
you obviously can read their resume and
see founder but what were you guys
advised when you are like surveying
other companies yeah so when we talk to
a lot of companies you know I think the
first step they try to do is see
internally whether that is 1 p.m. with
that sort of mindset especially the data
driven curiosity using data to help
answer versus you know just going with
product intuition because I think it's
very important for this growth PM
to look at a lot of data in fact you
know George Lee who was the head of
growth at Instagram puts this really
well he
the scariest day is when your metrics go
down but the second scariest day is when
your metrics go up and you don't know
why so the growth pian really has to
have that mindset of what is it what is
really driving each metric that day and
truly understanding the behavior behind
it you know they have to have the grasp
for that so the reason they look at
internal PM first is simply for one
reason which is social capital you know
meaning you know the growth team has the
onus of you know working with all other
teams in a more collaborative way
because if they were just focused on
what they were doing it probably
wouldn't work you're running a lot of
experiments you may need to make tweaks
to the product you may also have to make
design changes and when you're often
establishing a team early on you don't
have all the resources so you've got to
work with the product team you've got to
work with the engineering team so having
a PM who already has that internal
social capital and can you know debate
or you know ideas and experiments and
convince people on why that's required
yeah
is an easier move but not all companies
are able to do that so sometimes you
have to hire externally because maybe
the two PM's are the three PM's you have
on your team
don't have that growth mindset you know
and it's worked in other cases too but I
think the most important lever you need
there to make sure the new person that
comes in as successful is that
endorsement from the senior leadership
especially the CEO that it's an
important function and you want everyone
to work together in sort of dig into
that a little bit more specifically were
you guys you know trialing people at
Airbnb or if it's just your first growth
person are you having like multiple
candidates do like a month at a time
competing with each other how do you how
do you actually pick the person so I'll
give you a book recommendation this is a
book called worker rules okay my last
loboc which is probably the best book
I've read about hiring and there's two
things they talks about in that book
basically he's trying to answer the
question what makes a great hire and two
things that comes out of that is one is
cognitive ability like problem-solving
skills effectively and the other one is
like can you do the work so when we did
hire Bambi
the second was very very critical
basically can you do the work so we
would put them at like 4:00 p.m. we're
just like here's a growth problem most
likely something that we actually are
facing right now or something that we
face like a couple months ago where we
and a little bit more about we basically
asked them to give us your best
recommendation like how should we solve
this and the output of that is maybe you
spend 24 hours making a presentation and
you spend an hour
presenting it for the panel and
basically that that helps us determine
can you do the job in a much better way
than you would do an interview interview
ask hypothetical questions but it does
have a real use cases but you take a nap
spend an hour actually talking through
things yeah you can ask a ton of
detailed follow-up questions on very
specific things so that's basically what
we did once you've hired someone you've
hired someone like like I don't I'm not
sure if I believe in in like three
months
trial because you have to give up a job
in order to get higher somewhere so
there are some downsides but leaving
your previous jobs in terms of
internally so the way work there and B
is that engineer would join a derby and
different teams would pitch that
engineer and we would look for those
characteristics that I mentioned earlier
for the kind of people that would be
except good for growth and and we
basically would spend time with them and
kind of figure out if they fit what the
kind of person that we were looking for
and not everyone did and that's totally
fine there lots of other teams you can
work on but some people were like I
wanted a growth from day they're just
what kind of came just like I want even
the girls team yeah and then that's just
pretty awesome
and I was sure for you as well honor
yeah I think that you know different
companies obviously have different
models um I have seen at least two
companies that actually had the model of
come work with us for three days not a
month but you know even if you get
someone to work with you for two days
you have a you get a lot more color into
their personality how they think how
they collaborate with other team members
and how much of the job do they really
understand right so those are elements
you can get a sense of and some really
young startups do that they in fact
offer it as a paid vacation day or ask
them you know the interview is to
negotiate that but they do it obviously
with a select few so you can't do that
with everyone that was an interesting
approaches are with a couple of them in
other cases you could probably you know
today there are so many growth teams out
there you can actually hire someone
from a growth team like you know
Facebook has more than 2,000 people and
a lot of Facebook growth folks are now
at other companies and similarly you
know you can hire now from lots of other
teams right Airbnb scrotum is hundred
people big ubers growth team is 500
people they so I think growth teams are
no longer novel concept and so founders
have said that they find it fairly easy
versus five years ago to sort of tap
into that you know growth PM recruiting
pool and is it fairly easy to suss out
the people who are very effective on
those growth team so you're hiring
someone from Facebook and you're like
we're growing pick a product like a ten
percent month-over-month how do you know
it's that person that you're hiring
that's affecting that change yeah no
that's hard right it's not easy to do
but I think that's what Gustav's example
of presenting your problem during the
interview and seeing how they think
through that and react gives you a
better pulse for is this person really
wired for what we are trying to build Oh
case you know use many people assume
that if it's from Facebook they'll know
everything they'll know all the tools
but it was a so it's a social network at
the end of the day and the way you grow
a social network is very different from
how you grow ecommerce so how do you
grow something like travel which has
extremely low velocity of use so I think
you have to always test the person in
the realm of your context to feel to
test out two things one do they have the
depth of understanding that you need
about the problems you're solving and
are they able to bring their own
creativity versus just saying at
Facebook this was the experiment Mira
and me do it you know because it's not
Apple still it's absolutely the approach
that's like the key thing here so like
if you worked on Facebook then you will
be a dreaming da you Mau and like those
kind of metrics which actually didn't
apply to your MBA at all those are not
them econometrics we cared about at all
so if that's you you've got answers like
I'm sure looking at these metrics when I
mean value par MB then you were in
thinking hard enough about the type of
product MMB was so I think the signal
you get from having someone spent an
hour presenting a solution we don't
expect you should know the specific
channel tactics or any of those things
like that would be great if you do but
you don't that's not really what we're
looking for we're looking for you the
creativity and the ability to like solve
the problem and come up with like
how would I like a common question and
in that challenge would be what are the
metrics that you would use to evaluate
whether you have solved this or not yeah
and that's kind of like it's not like
you just have to think and use the
product and you can come up with what
those metrics are gotcha okay and so now
let's assume we have a growth team going
when should we start thinking about paid
marketing yeah I think just because you
have a growth team doesn't mean you
should start doing paid marketing a lot
of companies actually didn't you know
the growth team can actually really
spend a lot more time on the one or two
organic channels that you know the
product has been doing very well on
including reference mmm
you know good stuff and sure can talk a
lot about referrals from Airbnb but I
think the big mistake I see companies
doing the moment they had a growth team
they feel like they have to give them a
marketing budget and that you know that
suddenly the company has to go from
organic to paid and that's the biggest
mistake I've seen because you know paid
marketing will give you some results you
know for sure but you would you won't
know the retention of those users for a
while and so how do you know whether all
the experiments you're doing in a quote
and the acquisition of these customers
is good or not
long-term and second if you're a startup
the longer you can wait to use paid
marketing you should to the extent you
can actually get a lot of it from word
of mouth or you know bid are all through
even SEO or referrals you should you tap
into those first before you turn into
peak marketing you can always experiment
a little bit with paid marketing here
and there just to get a sense for which
channels you might tap anew but it
should you know at least in the second
and third year of your startup that
should not be your main channels hmm I
would say the amazing thing about a paid
marketing is that is the tactic you can
deploy with zero time basic can start
tomorrow and you can buy lots of stuff
that's great most most most channels
don't have that opportunity the biggest
problem though is that if you aren't
making the money back to your spending
you don't have anything like literally
you don't have anything so let's say I
bought a thousand users and I they're
not I'm not charging enough to make the
money back to spend on them well have
you I really haven't learned much
because I can't buy another thousand
users is eventually that strategy will
fail
so the only way that the paid marketing
works if you have high LTV high enough
so you can recoup the cost of the
marketing that you spend that's does the
only way it really works and you kind of
need to be sure that those cohorts and
the retention of those paid marketing
users are actually worth as much as the
previous ones so once you get the answer
to that one then then you have a lot of
opportunity mm-hmm
the hard thing at that at that point
becomes around measurement so the more
different marketing channels you have
guys be pretty good at measurement not I
mean it's not like it's rocket science
but you have to you have to do it and
people fail often in the measurement
site and in the in the early days if you
have a free product you won't really
learn anything from do your marketing
you just just shouldn't do it at all
like you might do it in the in the
product kind of customer development
face you just get a few users but that's
when you're talking about less than a
thousand users but but if it's a free
product marketing won't really help you
mmm and so aside from you know jumping
into paid marketing without knowing
these these stats what are the other big
mistakes people make I think let's see I
see some mistakes around the word
incrementality so so basically people
think that buying branded traffic on
google with my brand is is incremental
know that it's not incremental it's
usually not even marketing it's a salt
of your product growing through a
different mean let's say I told you
about a urban being you went to Google
you type in there and being a click on
the brand ad that's not marketing that's
just actually this channel the marketing
the marketing piece here is when you
type in apartment rentals in San
Francisco or vacation rentals in Miami
that's that's actually the the real
nombre marketing so that's the
incremental marketing that that you're
getting the data otherwise wouldn't be
getting and that's why it's key to think
about experimentation
this is true for say remarketing so
remarketing there's a lot like every
single click you get from your marketing
isn't incremental either so you have to
think about a way how can I actually
measure myself to think to know what
that the clicks that I'm paying for are
actually people that wouldn't have
otherwise gotten to my product and start
using the product so the word
incrementality
I think is just something that people
can tend to forget and there's basically
the answer to most of those things is
experimentation yeah and I think the
second one I would say is coming up with
metric
the right set of metrics and holding
yourself accountable to even measuring
the results of the experiment is another
idea that I've seen mistakes happen too
often people are just focused on
acquisition of customers and not the LTV
other attention especially after the
experiments and if you don't measure
that you actually don't know whether
that experiment was good or not before
you sort of make it mainstream but I've
seen time and time again companies do
that mistake where they just look at the
growth and they forget about measuring
the retention of those users even two
weeks down the line or four weeks down
the line if you can't tag the users the
about through paid marketing and and you
know downstream what they do compared to
the people that didn't come in you're
lost yeah the numbers might look good
but essentially you're lying to yourself
right like you have no idea very often
specific I mean specifically display
channels yeah we'll look radically
different than any other uses you
acquired from any other channels that
people like oh I spent a ton of money on
display marketing and now they don't
perform the way that every other user
don't do is like of course but search
marketing might be a little bit
different but but display they will be
radically different yeah the other
mistake I've seen companies do is when
they establish the growth team and even
do paid marketing they will try all
channels you know fragmenting the
budgets across four or five different
channels and if you ask companies that
have done it really well they would say
for a long time two channels gave 70% of
their user traffic so you know focus is
extremely important yeah easy to like go
and spend across six different channels
especially if you're an e-commerce
company you have influencers you have
YouTube your Instagram your Facebook you
have Pinterest and you think like all of
this looks cool but it's more important
to really identify those one or two
channels that are scalable and really
focus on optimizing those was just doing
six things that early yeah I mean that's
exactly what we do I see like I've tried
almost every channel but eventually you
realize that you're way better than your
competitors at certain channels and you
just go for those because that's where
the numbers are coming from like you
know we could hang out on snapchat all
day and like maybe that would work if we
were the best in the game but if you're
just average it's so easy to just fall
below also turns out that bath
the growth of all the marketing habits
on Facebook and Google so it like we are
going towards consolidation here that
that you most likely if you become a
billion-dollar company will figure out
one of those two channels mm-hmm
so let's shift from kind of the founder
perspective to the employee perspective
so Ken ruff asked the question if you're
working at a company that is not very
data driven how might you go about
trying to convince your leadership team
to prioritize data and potentially start
a growth team what do you think yeah so
I actually ran into this quite a lot
when we were interviewing a lot of
growth teams honestly I don't think I
have one magical answer for this I think
in talking to a few teams that were able
to influence this what they did very
well was you know a communicating even
if they need be over communicating so
this one particular team gave me an
excellent template of an email that they
sent to the whole company and I think
they very strategically did it at
Saturday at 7 a.m. even they're like the
email was done by Friday and it would
just highlight stats but in the context
of what drove the launches that week or
experiments that ran that week and they
would have fun anecdotes on you know the
outcome on there and their rationale on
the outcome and one of the scrotum leads
told me that sending it Saturday 7:00
a.m. with these Nuggets and data really
caught the attention of the CEO and so
sometimes he would engage by forwarding
it to the respective folks saying why
did this come down you know he just
wanted to know right because this was
the one snapshot that he was getting
about how the week actually went so
that's one way I have seen you know some
teams have gotten to influence at least
the rest of the company and it actually
changed the culture of other teams and
that company that everyone started
sending sort of a data report and so it
doesn't mean your decision-making moves
towards only data so I think that's the
constant tension the growth team uses
data and then you can you can have the
product team thinking well why is
everything based on data shouldn't it be
based on intuition yeah and I think
there's always a balance
and especially early in the startup
you're still building out a lot large
portion of your product roadmap you need
to have got an inducing about what the
customer wants not everything is from
the data so it's right to have some sort
of balance but to ignore data completely
is the other side of the challenge and
so in some cases it has worked honestly
in two or three cases where I spend a
lot of time with the growth leads it
didn't work
the CEOs just never engaged on it and if
you don't if you can't align with the
leadership team you know I have
personally seen those growth leads leave
and it doesn't mean it's a make or a
break you know the company can still
figure out other ways to do it but
there's no one magical solution the
leadership and especially the CEO has to
be inclined to buy into it I couldn't
agree more so even if you believe let's
say your company doesn't pay a lot
attention to data there's always data
it's just not surface like the did is
always there you might not be tracking
it but it's there somewhere so the first
thing I would do at that point you start
making sure you track the data make sure
it goes somewhere that people can look
at maybe it goes into an email me
because in a database and it goes in a
dashboard just somewhere people can look
at it the second thing is like I think
I'm assuming that this this comes from a
company that's doing okay mmm-hmm like
if you basically are doing okay you're
not looking at data then you're
confusing correlation and causation
you're like oh I did all these things
and the company's doing great yeah the
thing is you don't really know and you
really really really don't know and
people are there's so many of these
confusions that people have around what
costs the company to be successful and
the only really way to do this to use to
look at data so I think to can and this
and this question I would basically get
the data find a good place to send out
the data maybe that's email maybe that's
a dashboard in the wall maybe that's
something else just make sure the data
gets out there and then find a way to to
prove out what is what is actually
driving your growth like what is the
number one driver it might not be the
latest launch you did it might be the
fact that people that Google AdWords is
working really well or the funnels
working really well you got a better
payment mechanism it might not just be
the latest launch so I think at that
point you get the data and then like
find a way to service the data
in the right way yeah one other new ones
I'll add to that you know often the
problem is you use data and you expose
problems no one likes problems people
are looking for solutions so one
tactical way especially if you're trying
finding it very hard within a company to
get someone to listen is show the
solution with data I mean you know
there's a famous story about how you
know uber always said they would never
do cash but they went to India where
there are no credit cards so how do you
convince the team that did not want to
do cash to actually allow cash on
delivery yeah
or you know to do a different form of
integration run an experiment and prove
the adoption is really 10 times better
than the alternate that's another way
and then the person really has to
explain why they are still gonna turn
down your idea right so make it you know
go with solutions if you're finding it
harder then just exposing problems and
ultimately eventually we're gonna get to
a point where you poking around these
expect these examples these experiments
yourself and until you have the
permission to do that I would just do it
anyway this is like one of one of these
small experiments in one country like
Facebook that we're learning tons of
experimenting on specific countries all
the time to try new things I would just
like to run an experiment and see if you
can prove out something something's up
yeah usually I mean a company of this
size you would probably already be able
to find people that you're working with
who want to start doing this stuff so
you just dedicate a couple hours to an
experiment you're you're good from there
okay so Kate Nolan asked a question for
you and particular group stuff and what
is a product lead for growth actually do
which was your previous title at Airbnb
and why did the team decide that it
needed to exist oh so my role even be
before I left was matching the practice
on the on the growth team that's
basically the practically lead role we
had a number of different teams some of
them were more requiring more domain
expertise than others so there was some
teams ronnapee marketing or on SEO
maybe referrals to requires some
specific experience in those areas but
in general they were
growth pm's that could move across
different products in different
different areas pretty fast so
it wasn't like there was super deep
domain expertise but effectively
practically for growth it just a pract
manager with okay that's an easy one we
do have more Airbnb questions but we can
kind of expand this to cover the growth
post on you
so Tim Knight the following question
asked when Airbnb moved internationally
how does the strategy change from what
you're doing in the in the US so this is
almost before my time now everybody's a
little bit different than most companies
everybody has a global network affect
most companies do not have that which
means most of the countries and be kind
of entered when they set the foot first
foot and on the on the airport in those
countries they already had host nobody
had bookings yeah very rarely the lists
he had nothing most companies do not
have that that effect so most companies
have to do something to grow somewhere
month you have to make sure your site is
available in their language you have to
maybe if your marketplace launched in a
different way or at payment mechanisms
immediate didn't really have that
problem we had several different
organizations driving in national growth
that ever be on the growth team I can
speak to with the things that we found
the most important number one
translation the translation is super
super critical there was a guy called
Jason Katz Brown who before I even join
how launch and be in 24 languages
something like that he built this single
handily himself there Wow some stuff you
can look at online around this how he
did that but that was absolutely
critical it's critical for conversion
because if you don't understand the site
you won't know really how to use it it's
critical for SEO if you aren't
translated then people typing something
on Google in different language they
won't find their me because you won't
rank so translation was absolutely
critical then in general when we thought
internationally we had a strategy that
we the first layer we said it we'll call
it what we called product gaps is the
product broken in a certain country like
something about experience broken very
obvious things would be well China South
Korea and Russia will be three countries
where a lot of things were often broken
if you didn't do anything specific to
them so no Facebook doesn't work Google
doesn't work Google Play might not work
there's a bunch of these things you kind
of have to change most other countries
there are fewer like the infrastructure
are the same so people use Facebook
Google's a lot of a lot of the other
infrastructure
that we would use in us is available
accessible in these countries so you
just have to do some minor optimizations
around site speed and in translation and
those things so that's the first thing
that the product caps fixing that and
fixing translation solves most of it
mm-hmm the I am not 100% believer that
you have to do a ton of work to make the
culture of a certain country accept a
product so if you fix the product fixed
translation now saying that all this
concept doesn't work in my country for
my experience most product don't have
that problem most things that grow big
in most countries will eventually grow
big in all countries like they're very
very early cases we're like oh this
country don't we'll have to change the
practice or the cultural difference and
it will never click I just don't really
I just haven't seen too many examples
however that seems to be the number one
thing that people say oh Japan is so
different I got changed entire product
in Japan usually it's not the case just
usually not the case and usually use it
as irtual to reveal these elements I
think a lot of time if you rely just on
data to form your opinions that's when
you can run into this black hole so you
know Instagram for example when they
launched in the Middle East this product
which is you know heavily used by women
in the US and another developed
countries all of a sudden saw a huge
spike in male profile users in Middle
East and they were wondering why they're
not able to recruit the women but they
launched a user research team that
traveled to Middle East who then who
then found out that a lot of these users
were women but they were afraid of
harassment and so their pictures on
Instagram or the profile pictures were
all men so you know you have to be on
the ground you know no amount of data
would have told you because your data
would show that 90% were male right you
have to be on the ground doing focus
groups and use the research to
understand you know why is that the case
and can the product make small tweaks or
you know small changes in their profile
appearance for those you know to respect
the elements of that culture were there
any other radically different techniques
people used internationally I mean I
think I've also heard it I've heard
about Japan consistently but I think
it's more it's not like the
changes completely but what people are
comfortable sharing might be different
like people are probably not as
comfortable sharing pictures yeah you
know publicly in Japan so if you were
using that as a tactic like Facebook and
the early days was using tactic as you
know photo tags as a way for you to come
back and sign into Facebook like it
wouldn't have worked in Japan right so
those are the elements you have to
really pay attention to it's not like a
radical dramatical difference you don't
have to change your product
fundamentally yeah I guess like QR codes
right in Asia it took off yeah yeah here
not really yeah I think they get well
though yeah like we just haven't seen
that yet but we are going to yeah you
know often people say that like to me
like Oh US will number acts of QR codes
because we don't like QR codes I think
it's not the case I mean the two simple
reasons u.s. does not use QR code is
iPhone and Facebook because iPhone did
not come and will come with an inbuilt
QR code reader it didn't make it it made
it very hard for anybody who had a QR
code and Facebook which is the app for
the largest usage did not have offer a
QR code in China
you had the phones with inbuilt QR code
readers and we checked on it and so if
you make it more mainstream yeah and it
improved the can ease of use and
convenience for the user why not so so
yeah I agree with all that
here's a common mistake that people make
they're like oh I want to go
internationally I did that it's not
working
there must be something with that
country that's not working oh people
don't like to use Facebook a sign up
option that must be the main reason why
it's not working this country people
don't use credit cards but people don't
like to use phone numbers for sign up
well I got all of those things over the
years and we ran experiments trying all
those things and they are marginal
differences like basically you change
one payment method you get like a five
or ten percent difference but not it's
not like the majority to change Facebook
to not Facebook and you get it as a
small small change by not dramatic we
even launched phone number signups
that's also pretty marginal change if
you already have a bunch of sign ups so
these easy cultural solution reasons for
100 isn't growing in those countries
rarely is the case now we should try to
figure out is how does it grow in the
first country like if it's growing the
first country thanks to Google AdWords
or SEO and it's not growing the second
country or maybe
don't have any SEO in the second country
maybe I don't have any adverse actually
in the second country maybe my marketing
isn't doing anything there like that
might be more so it's again it's like
returning to the data and knowing why
you're growing yes yes yes and it's not
like like it's very easy to come in in
these situations and give you very
specific examples it's very easy to say
I am an expert in Sweden so much you
guys are not I can tell you this I can
tell you this I can work in Sweden and
you will trust me because I'm an expert
in Sweden now I'm most likely going to
be wrong right it's like you can't
really be expert in one country without
knowing all the other countries and kind
of see the patterns of launching country
by country being a country specific
expert just isn't worth as much but it's
so easy to to think that that's the main
thing that's going to change and so were
those hires that you were making you're
like I'm the Airbnb Japan person like is
that something that existed me had
different because we had multiple
different jobs and I get the growth
team's job was like make sure that proc
works make sure the product gross using
add we weren't in charge of talking to
government we weren't charge and talking
to press right we weren't in charge of a
lot of these different local things so
we ought to always had local offices
that did a lot of this work on the
ground getting hosts talking to
governments talking to media there's
always people doing that that were
outside the craft team so we were always
doing those things but in terms of like
a new startup trying to grow grow like
those things are critical for the
business but but what's critical for the
growth is to really go through that
that's the kind of like step by step
first is their product gaps is this some
some motivation well the pack isn't
working is it translated is there
something about the growth sources that
is different in these countries there's
basically the three steps you have to go
through if all of them are true when
you're not growing well that's a harder
problem usually it's one of those three
things okay yeah and I would add that
you especially given the three elements
that Gustav laid out for that you don't
actually need to have a growth team in
every country you can actually do a bulk
of your international growth city in San
Francisco I mean that's what Facebook
did they launched a growth team and they
had 50 million I may use because they
were dead worried how they were gonna
scale and they needed to scale
internationally I mean what's up the
entire team is in San Francisco but
they're a majority of the user base it's
outside the US so you don't really need
it's the opposite the opposite if you
have a local growth team the chance of
that growth team having the same amount
experience and basically compounding it
Effects of growth as the team s average
disco is much smaller yeah yeah
compounding again so shifting to like
thinking about growth internationally to
thinking about growth and different
kinds of businesses
Steve Harrison asked how things differ
between a B to C and a b2b company when
it's going from zero to the first 1,000
users I think it's really different
depending on the type of product I think
just saying b2c versus b2b is too broad
here's why you know consumer start if
you're a consumer startup you know it's
a different type of a growth approach
that you use from whether you're a
social network to an on-demand or travel
yeah right each of those levers tactics
that you use will be different and also
the time you launch will be different if
you take b2b again that's too broad
because you have different you know I
would put b2b in two bucket three
buckets now so one is the
consumerization of the enterprise you
have the slack you have the Dropbox they
have very similar elements to a consumer
startup now not all growth channels are
similar even for those companies that
are nuances because of the b2b nature
but you can have a growth team sooner
because the adoption of those products
is more consumer driven right within
companies different teams and different
members the second
you know the second and third B to B
type actually I would categorize them in
a generic bucket which is sales right
sales driven but there are two models
one is the a class Ian kind of model
where they didn't just hire a head of
sales and plastron huge enterprise deals
from day one in fact they figure out
ways for the product grow organically
through affiliate partnerships or you
know through their own word-of-mouth and
website so it's much slower growth if
you will at the start but a much less
spend on sales and marketing right as a
function of revenue the third bucket is
the enterprise sales the typical
enterprise sales where it even the first
ten users is not about getting two
thousand users but getting that first
five large enterprise contracts I'm
talking about like hundred thousand two
hundred thousand dollar contract
and you spending a lot of time and
effort in making sure those PHY really
work very well and using that lens to
sort of scale right and then you build
up your sales team with the traditional
sales models so it's really different
where you fall in the spectrum I'm sure
there are more nuances than the three I
laid out but it's extremely important
for you first to figure out where you
fall in the spectrum and then depending
on that the things that you would do
whether you would invest in a growth
team or not really differ right so even
if you take slack and Dropbox they did
invest in growth quite early but they
also had to enterprise invest in
enterprise sales you know you can't just
grow your user base you also have to
grow your revenue so that is a fine
balance between how much you invest in
growth versus how much you invest in
sales but if you take the example of a
social network and a consumer you most
of it is really driven by growth right
it's all about the user and it's all
about the engagement the advertising is
a form of monetization so they're the
effort has to start early the scale of
the team will be a lot bigger this is
why face because the two thousand people
growth team while slack probably has a
30 people growth team right so there's a
big difference in how about a giant
sales team was that but a giant sales
team yes like yeah yeah a giant-sized
yeah it is it's a big sale I mean it's
moving more towards enterprise sales
yeah I think the many things they're
similar so anything from like activation
to retention how you measure those
numbers they're very similar between
kind of the framework that Facebook came
up with that growth accounting and what
you apply to an enterprise or or b2b
kind of kind of solution you can you can
apply similar type of models when you're
a value in those companies I think the
big question you should ask yourself
when you're working on on selling to cut
cut to companies or enterprises is
what's the level of the involvement I
need to have in that sale too close to
sale like do I need to go to their
office to meet with them a bunch of
times
well then growth teams isn't gonna like
make those meetings happen faster now if
I just need to start in the think about
the top of the funnel like how many of
those leads do I need so new field
around automating of
kind of early outreach or automated
sales which is kind of have a lot of the
same type of type of tactics that's
coming from growth teams like how do you
reach a lot of relevant people with a
relevant message and personalized
message well that's all things you can
automate them those are things that you
don't really need to start a new email
every single time and a lot of cool
things you can do there if even if you
selling to enterprises but and and the
same goes for like the entire kind of
CRM fund all of those things but when it
comes to the actual clothes the level of
involvement that's still a question that
that you can't just solve like through a
self-serve model all the time mm-hmm
but I think there's gonna be a lot of
more things happening here and I think
we've funded a lot of companies in this
space anything from sourcing to
qualifying and the early early part of
the funnel that will help companies with
sales immensely cool so we did have
another question and that is what is
product channel fit how would you guys
define that so this is a word I hardened
for the first time this week actually
but maybe I should have heard of earlier
I think it's brilliant brilliant
definition so so what I used to say when
I was at Airbnb was most large companies
Google might be the exception here grow
really big through a channel like
there's some platform they sit on top of
when they're finding all the users that
chat platform could be Google it could
be Facebook you could Instagram could
the app store could be Google Play but
there's just some other platform they
just rarely grow out of nothing and I
think it's important for companies to
figure out what that platform is going
to be for you and there's a great slide
by a tea from from LinkedIn and one of
his decks they basically is talks about
how do I figure out what channels that
I'm going to to bet on and the initial
question for for answering that question
what channel should I bet on is how do
people discover this product today if
you have a product with a very rare use
case you're most likely going to go to
Google most questions you don't ask
yourself or ask your fans very often you
go to Google to find the answer and
let's say I want to buy flowers you
don't may buy fires that often you
usually go to Google or or some like
that to find that it you end up on Yelp
anyway but that's basically how people
start those kind of questions because
it's not a frequent occurrence the same
would travel the reason why Google is so
powerful and travel is because we don't
have
an app that we go to every time to look
at for travel if a traveler wants to
rise a year we go to Google and we're
most likely going to go to a place that
we never been before so you also go to
Google so that's kind of a kind of an
example of how you figure out the
channel that's true for you and and if
you don't find that channel you're going
to rely on growth growth that you can't
really influence that much you're gonna
write on on word-of-mouth which is great
but not sufficient
you're gonna rely on all kinds of stuff
that you just don't have as much control
over but most of these channels you
could like SEO Adwords Facebook morality
referrals all of these different
channels are things that you can
actually drive yourself and make an
impact if you don't figure out which of
these channels that match your product
or even sales then then you're not gonna
have as much opportunity to influence
your breath yeah and I think the
interesting thing I've seen more
recently or not even that recently in
the last five seven years is there are
two or three products that I've actually
relied on the product to do the
marketing initially uber and lyft are
classic examples of that no one was
actually searching online where can I
find a taxi they were looking for maybe
the contact number of a taxi yeah you
know you could advertise a little bit bi
behind that but the biggest way the you
know the word of mouth happened was
actually when your friend arrived in an
uber and you were like how did you get
here or when they were leaving a party
and they said look I have this new
service right so if you're doing
something really cool and that's easy
and convenient then the you invariably
get your users to talk about it right
which is word-of-mouth
you know I've seen a similar thing which
monza Bank does in UK you know it's a
new kind of bank and no one's usually
looking for a bank online you look for
it when you first want to open a bank
account and maybe after school when
you've graduated what they ended up
doing is they offer this really cool
digital it's a digital bank but a
digital sort of your own personal
finance management tool and so how do
you advertise for that so they send you
a prepaid card which is a glowing pink
card so imagine you're in London in the
night at a bar and you take this card
everyone's wondering what is this right
so you know in your early days there are
ways you can figure out for the product
to speak for that for yourself
get that to generate what of math
especially if you find some of these
channels are pretty hard to tap into
early on yeah well if you're doing
something really novel you know if
you're like coinbase and you get some
like buy bitcoin or you're like Vanguard
you're like buy an index fund like
there's that kind of thing yeah but I
could see that help yeah cool so this is
just going over something kind of we
talked about already but a startup
Sanatana asked how do you prioritize the
metrics for growth I think this is a
it's related but just so people know
that yeah how you feel about it
specifically I would start with the
funnel like how does the funnel look
like what is the first step that people
do with your product was the last step
yes thank you go through a entire funnel
make sure you know what the drop-off
rate is in every single step of them
make sure you know which are the most
important steps in that funnel and then
you kind of after that II bit okay which
one here is like the biggest like try to
benchmark each each of these steps if
you have a lot of channels like do the
funnel by channel and see kind of
benchmark the channel the channels as
well like what's the conversion I have
for these different channels I don't
think there's a super clear answer what
we did everybody's what we call
opportunity assessment is basically you
try to figure out everything from like
what's the impact I can have on a
project what's the actual chance I think
I can like what's the that like Allah
doesn't actually hit it how much effort
is involved in kind of testing out the
first version of that it kind of depends
like the outcome of that is hopefully a
good prepared list in general maybe
actually that's probably where I would
start you say trying to make the funnel
to make the opportunity assessment cool
yeah and I think too often startups are
caught in this between how many metrics
is feasible versus to have too many
versus too little yeah right you know
I'm very analytical by nature so I'd say
you always have very few most startups
that I see actually measure less than
what they should be but if you are
working in a company that actually does
is not very data-driven and it's gonna
take time for you to sort of buy into
this view of using data to help inform
decisions then you know use the funnel
framework that could stuff laid out and
even prioritize on top of that when
you're young as a start-up in the first
and second year really the two things
that matter is the bottom of your funnel
you have lots of people coming to the
website or to your app how many are
actually converting to a final
transaction or usage or purchase and see
the ones that are dropping off in the
last two steps I would even start with
the last step because that's the lowest
hanging fruit because users that did not
convert but went through like 80 percent
of your funnel know about your service
your product have heard so find a way to
get them back right so you know and I
think Alex from Facebook refers to this
as the marginal user even in when you're
running growth experiments if you're new
and you growth team is new first
prioritize your churned user they
already know about here right so figure
out why they left well it's not it
that's why Shopify doesn't let you
customize the checkout right because
like so many people had just like oh I
have all this new creative way for you
to buy something like that nananananana
stuff like we figured this out over
millions of purchases right yeah yeah so
this is a another Airbnb question
Bradley back Amir asks what are the two
things that have driven the majority of
Airbnb is growth today I think a lot of
people would be curious the number one
driver in beast growth is word of mouth
so let me start off with a really great
product a new concept and word of mouth
is critical for everyone be compared to
the other products because it's
something that is pretty radical like
it's not like you're gonna be like the
concept of having strangers come to your
home or the compost is staying in
someone else's home for all of us the
first time we heard about it was weird
yeah it wasn't something that was just
like natural like yeah I'm gonna do that
it's something we thought about for the
first time most people's initial
reactions like I would never do that but
we all did did that eventually it just
took some time so for that reason that
is so radically different kind of like
uber was the first time I heard about
someone getting in the car with a
stranger from home at night I'm like
that's so weird
but now we all do it yeah both of those
reasons I think that those are those
companies because it's so radical and so
different what a mouth is critical
because you kind of need a friend to
trust
you why you should start using this now
at some point the brand got really big
and people started hearing about and be
and before they even tried it or had had
a friend do it they still trusted it and
then you can do a lot more other
channels that was probably why I why
word of mouth is the strongest mm-hmm
after that we invested in paid marketing
we invested in referrals we invest in
SEO all them are sizable channels
word-of-mouth is the biggest one on the
host side where the mouth is even bigger
oh yeah that makes sense yeah usually
like you know I'm making all this money
doing air B&B you should try it yeah in
the early days of everybody was still
paying dead quiet the hose right so it's
it's hard to acquire hosts like through
search ads I think on the display side
I'm not sure everybody did too much in
the very beginning I know Oberyn lifted
a ton to acquire drivers yeah through
display ads and in the beginnings that
was critical for them referrals has
always been strong on the guest and a
host side for everybody lyft and uber so
that's an important thing is kind of
like just a kind of a thing that pushes
you over the edge to actually tell your
friend to start hosting or to start
traveling Edwin B Performance Marketing
on the traveler side though was very
critical fare and be in the very
beginning so people were searching for
travel on Google and they might even be
searching for the travel travel there me
already was and there was a big
opportunity for everybody to buy
keywords on Google so that was very
important very very early days for
people already knew what they were
looking for now the travel the total
keyword set of all keywords for travel
is enormous so even be every was
bringing a lot of time on that like the
toll the total amount of money spent on
travel keywords in the world is in the
in probably in tens of billions and
that's a very important observation by
the way which is it's not just Airbnb
and I have you know seen a lot of
startups in the last four years the this
both successful startups have heard of
mother as the biggest channel for a long
time that's a sign a strong product
market fit you start paying soon it's
you know it's it's really hard to get
out of that and it's very hard for you
to continue to scale with paid marketing
yeah it was there a dial at Airbnb that
you go you're using to turn up
word-of-mouth is there any way just like
make a better
people are money we did a lot of
research like I would say there's three
moments where people talk about travel
okay how one is when I'm about to go to
trip one one is when I ask them tell my
friends I'm going to trip
how are you staying I'm sitting in B
this new thing we came back and you tell
everyone oh it came back from the trip
told me we're staying that's one thing
and then when your friends are going in
a trip that's when you were like oh I
want to show you about this thing I
tried to Airbnb it's pretty awesome
those are the three moments they don't
happen every day they're not like uber
and lyft but literally you're doing a
trip every day and you get a chance to
talk about it every day but they do
happen and it's a kind of a very strong
time when like a powerful time where you
can talk about it yeah I always wanted
to figure out social media but that's
tricky there are so much content posting
about trips in social media there's
probably one of the top things we all
post but too tied back to a brand to say
that these photos you're not posting on
Facebook and Instagram are tied back to
the the place I'm staying in it wasn't
obvious and it was pretty hard but it's
something we explored with a lot and I
was a lot of things we've done a lot of
things there but it's something we could
have done a lot more but I think there's
there's a lot of other companies that
succeeded better we're tying the
experience you're having with a product
in social media back to back to the
brand who's that
I think Nike is a good example okay is
something that I Nike have this thing
where you basically posting an Instagram
photo with a Nike logo that's basically
watermark on the photo oh that's like
when you're doing the run tracking yeah
I'm not sure how long like you will be
able to do that I feel like this is kind
of like marketing but that you should be
paying for Instagram even but it's
something that works pretty well and
it's something that I now know that you
use Nike when you went out for that run
I don't know that I used Airbnb when I
went on that trip but I don't know which
other things serviced I use when I were
experiencing that thing that I'm not
posting on Instagram that's pretty good
any other word-of-mouth tips on you from
your research I mean I think that it's
really comes down to your product market
fit I know it sounds pretty simple but
for Airbnb yes it may have been
conversations that he used but the very
fact that you went to a stranger's house
and stayed is something you think is
cool to talk about it's as simple as
that you're going to find a way to
mention it right
so for uber or lyft it was just the
convenience with which you could get a
ride from your home within two minutes
so you talk about things that are 10
better so I you know keep going back to
is your product really 10x better than a
incumbent solution then yes I think
ecommerce companies find this especially
challenging because in the world of paid
marketing you know everyone's trying to
market the same products to the same
user so how do you differentiate and you
know different companies have done
things differently so for example if C
you know it was founded by these three
amazing three or four amazing
influencers who had a lot of following
who literally were looking to them for
advice on makeup and skin care
so when Ipsy launched for the first two
years they literally could use word of
mouth to scale up to thousands of
subscribers because of the influencers
you know Emily from glaciated some
similar things she had a blog and she
did a lot of content marketing and you
know at our ended recommendations and
advice for people on skin care before
she sort of launched glossier and a
bunch of videos and a bunch of videos so
right so I think investing a lot of time
up front in why you are that person on
why you have the authority especially if
you're trying to sell a product that's
quite competitive can get you more
word-of-mouth
I mean Soylent Robb from Soylent did an
amazing job of launching silent and he
had lots of followers on his blog and
his first few you know ten thousands of
subscribers were because of his blog
right so I think you have to find a way
to resonate with an audience outside of
just performance marketing if you want
to leverage sort of MA cool yeah one
thing we spent time on ami was basically
if you were staying there being had
three friends coming with you capturing
the identities of those people yeah and
getting the relationship with them and
getting their emails we spent a lot of
time optimizing this because literally
there's like three times when people
booking with everything that could be
our audience and like we just made some
math I'm like where would I be in 2020
and I would be like half of the world
it's like basically they spend some time
in an Airbnb if you think about your
parents and everyone else's your booking
for that that you otherwise might not
have used a service to make sure that
they know that is it urban bee and then
they have an account
I think this those so some of the things
we spend time on anything else you want
to cover yeah I think we pretty much
just thank you yeah yeah it's great
thanks guys yeah thank you very much
you